I think India does have the capacity to
become a superpower first of all it is
by far the largest country Brazil
instead of reaching it has the capacity
that they dominant reach although having
a regional space in which to be a global
power is fine china as a race in east
asia united states has a base for
British tennis gear who traditionally
Britain and France have places within
their hemisphere so this is very
important secondly its size and its
resources as human resources or such
material resources given the capacity to
to really take advantage of a market
power part of what makes American
superpower is that people want access to
its market people want are influenced by
its level of wealth and over time
unlocking the potential of its people
India can achieve that kind of economic
superpower base without which is very
hard the low power ultimately you've got
to make a choice to invest in the fence
to be a simple and I know the Indian
government is making several steps in
this direction but over time the best
something has to be sustained in order a
superpower status to be retained it will
create antibodies and reactions from
your neighbors which carry a price and
the Indian government have to make its
choice a final point I think would be
about a system of government to be a
superpower you need to have a strong
absolutely get power from a strong
central political base the United States
although like India federally very
submit has been able to centralize power
against foreign policy dimensions around
the president so the Congress is very
powerful but it is movement or domestic
isn't conidia zone forest
that's a big questions where we can be
able to vote for similar type of
variable start from the center the
really plain active on foreign policy
while probably still being very federal
divided to some cases with domestic
policy this worth